so okay let's start off talking about
violence against women
and girls something i know you care
deeply about having been the director
of public prosecutions the most recent
figures show
that rape cases there are over 55 000
in the year to march 2020 and actual
convictions
less than 1500 what is going wrong
and how we're going to fix it well that
statistic is
shocking the idea that
you know 98 of
reported cases of rape don't end up um
with a charge or conviction is something
which would disturb everybody
it's part of a wider issue that i think
we have which is violence against women
and girls is
pernicious and you know we have
some cases some shocking cases that are
turning points in criminal justice
stephen lawrence was one of them on the
race issue
james bulger was another of them in
relation to
children and society sarah everard in a
in a way needs to be a turning point
terrible case and
grief unspeakable grief of her family
and friends it has to be a turning point
where we look again at violence against
women and girls
recognize the scale of it and understand
why it is that so many women girls
experience fear on our streets and at
home
why so many of those that are subjected
to abuse or sexual violence
feel they can't come forward at all to
the criminal justice system because nine
out of ten don't come forward
and then why so many feel that they
can't manage the journey through
criminal justice and
um this has been the issues that have
been there for a very very long time i
was grappling with them when i was
director of public prosecution
we need to we really need action now
just
you obviously are at the coal face of
some of this was there any cases that
particularly stuck out
for you or made you change your views
yeah i had a number of cases but one
particularly
was significant for me john and penny
clough
they lost their daughter their daughter
was
subjected to domestic abuse by her
partner
she hid it she didn't tell anyone
which often happens eventually
she was raped by her partner when she
was pregnant right
and she did come forward and tell her
parents and tell the police
um and um the perpetrator was then
arrested but released on bail and whilst
on bail he brutally murdered her
and so you went from domestic violence
to rape
to murder and john and pennycloth were
let down by the criminal justice system
so they wanted to see
me as director of public prosecutions
and i agreed to see them and
the day they were supposed to come and
see me was the day that
my daughter was born and so we had this
awful situation really where they'd lost
their daughter i just had a daughter
board
i've kept up with both of them they've
been campaigning for change and i now
campaign with them but
um it was that case um
that really has stuck in my memory that
that that transition
from from you know domestic violence
the fact that their daughter couldn't
felt she couldn't tell anyone
then on to rape then on to murder and
and then the criminal justice system
um let down the parents and we
campaigned together for change after
that
um but um it's just a small example of
just how pernicious violence against
women and girls is
in terms of what we actually do about it
though you
the the labour official account tweeted
that rape had been effectively
decriminalized
did you sanction that and was that a
responsible thing to do
well that quote those words
actually come from the victims
commissioner this is the independent
commissioner appointed by the government
vera bed she looked at the statistics
she looked at that particular statistic
that
you know less than two percent of cases
actually make it through the criminal
justice system
and those were her words of advice
actually to the government in her
report so whilst it's true that some
conservative mps
have complained about that actually i
think the bigger question is
having been given that advice what have
you done about it just in terms of what
they're doing about it the government
has got a rape review the consultation
is going to run
in summer you presumably support that
well
look i've been um
working with others on the issues of
balance against women and girls for many
many years we've had reviews we've had
consultations
we've had discussions we don't actually
need we know
any more of reviews we need action um i
had proposed a victim's law five years
ago yeah
on a cross-party basis and still nothing
has been done
about it and i think the strong feeling
um
from those that have campaigned on this
for many many years is you know
reviews all very well but we don't need
reviews we need
action and the pm he said in the
comments yesterday that you need social
and cultural change
do you think he's got the moral
authority to do that given some of the
remarks he's made in the past about
women
i'm glad that yesterday there was a
constructive tone in
parliament with all parties recognizing
that we must
treat the last week as a turning point
that is
a good thing um as for the prime
minister i mean
as as many of my female colleagues point
out to me in parliament you know this is
the prime minister that when they were
um going public with some of the things
that have been said to them
um the misogyny that they faced um
he dismissed dismissed it as humbug and
so
um i think he's got some way to go on
this but look yesterday was constructive
and if we are to do something about
violence and women against women and
girls
we need everybody to pull together i
think he's sexist
well i think that he was far too
dismissive of misogyny
i mean you know i remember the afternoon
in
parliament where women were standing up
and saying this is what has been said to
me and about me
and to dismiss that as humbug i think
um was obviously the wrong thing to do
but went was
was very raw for those women who were
going public while they're being said
about
them and and so let's go into kovid and
the inquiry and labour call in today for
that public inquiry the government's
still pushing
back on that um jonathan van tan said
yesterday that any inquiry now would be
to quote him an unwelcome distraction
for me personally
when i'm very focused on the vaccine
program he's got a point hasn't he that
this is maybe not the moment
look i think we need an inquiry um and
uh rachel reeves and i've spent a lot of
time with bereaved families
hearing their stories and they have been
the most difficult meetings i've had in
the last
year talking to those families and they
want closure they want justice they want
their
questions answered and we can't keep
saying now is not the time
we come out of restrictions you could
wait until after the
the vaccine program was completed well
we come out of the restrictions
in june um and we hope the country then
opens up we go back to
normal or a degree of normality and that
is the time to start this
inquiry and of course there's always the
argument this is not the right time
that's the argument the government put
forward last summer
at the end of the first wave we said to
the government have a rapid review so
you don't make the same mistakes in the
autumn
but they didn't and they made the same
mistakes but when the deputy chief
medical officer
says look we just get the vaccine
programme done and then we definitely
should do it
couldn't you wait till july i mean it's
only a few more weeks
well um you know whether it's june or
july of course nobody's going to quibble
over
june or july but what we're saying is
got to start as soon as the restrictions
are lifted
now if there's an argument for saying
that's july or august then fair enough
but i don't think we can just park it
off for years to come
okay and okay oncomid government
performance
you've talked a lot about the
government's failures in the past year
over covered but when you actually look
at the polling
they're 13 points ahead of labor boris
johnson's now rated higher than you when
it comes to who would be
the best prime minister if they've done
such a bad
job how come the public are much more
into
the conservatives and boris johnson than
they are into labor and care stamina
well
those polls have bounced around in the
autumn they were telling a different
story
i think what's happened is there was
undoubted incompetence and slowness to
act
last year whether it was going into the
lockdowns uh whether it was getting
test and trace and isolate working
whether in the initial stage it was
getting protective equipment to the
front lines they were
that was real incompetence um real
slowness
um and you know tragically we had a
second wave where there were more deaths
than the first weight
now we're in the vaccine roll out yeah
it's going well
and that's a good thing and we're
completely supportive of that
and i think that there's undoubtedly a
vaccine bounce
um for the government um and i will make
this
job hard doesn't it i want the vaccine
program to succeed and
i'm not going to say anything against it
and therefore you know if it rolls out
quicker or more efficiently than
anywhere else that is a good thing am i
hugely supportive but does it lead to a
vaccine bounce
in the polls i think it does it may not
be the only reason but it's very
significant
but it's hard to handle isn't it i mean
you're going into a massive set of
elections
and you really are in a bad place aren't
you particularly in scotland
well it's a pandemic and that makes
ordinary politics much more difficult
i took the decision that the labour
party would be a constructive opposition
support the government where it was the
right thing to do for example
the vaccine criticized them where they
were in the wrong
and i think that's the right approach to
have taken but we are in a pandemic
here in scotland we've got a new leader
anasawa who is
three weeks into office and doing a
fantastic job
who is utterly focused on what we need
in scotland which is a recovery and a
recovery
plan in terms of scotland what's success
for you is that holding seats rather
than losing seats
i mean we've got a challenge in scotland
we've got a new leader
who is already shifting the polls
positively for us there are clear
dividing lines now which is really
important because you've got the
scottish conservatives who want to go
back
to what we had before the injustice and
inequality of the system we had before
you've got the snp are increasingly
obsessed
with independence and putting that above
all else and then you've got scottish
labor saying the focus has to be on the
recovery the recovery
the recovery so there's a very clear
divide now going into these elections
that is what you're trying to sell but
in a generation labour have gone from
being the first party in scotland to the
third you've got 32
fewer seats than you had in the fast
parliament so my question shoot's really
simple
what's success for you here is it
holding seats
if you come out the other side of the
election in the same place as you went
in is that
a victory for you in those circumstances
we want to improve we're fighting for
every
vote um we're already seeing the polls
move
um a bit positively for us let that
continue
um our new leader anna sabor has been in
for less than three weeks but we're
fighting for every vote
and just finally suck here scotland is
your biggest problem
isn't it i mean labour's never won a
majority without scotland in the last
section you won
one out of 59 seats
is this your biggest problem as labour
leader is this the biggest barrier to
getting back
to number 10 for labour i'm here in
scotland and scotland is really
important to me and to the
labour party hopelessly very important
in these elections in terms of the make
up for the
parliament very important to the future
of the united kingdom and very important
at the general election
and we that's why we have to improve the
labour vote in scotland
rebuild trust and get back to winning
ways
in scotland we've got you know a
mountain to climb i accept that
but scotland is very important to me
into the labour class does it keep you
awake at night scotland worrying about
it
well it doesn't keep me awake at night
but i can't underestimate um
or over emphasize just how important
scotland is to me
and to the labour party and just finally
one more thing just on a referendum
if nicola sturgeon wins hollyrood
is that a mandate to call a second
referendum i think that in the middle of
a
pandemic a divisive
referendum would be the last thing that
scotland needs
what we need to focus on is the recovery
and this is a very clear dividing
the very idea that in 2021
as we come out of the pandemic and the
economy needs to be rebuilt the next few
years is going to be crucial for the
scottish economy
that we need divisive referendum which
will do nothing for rebuilding the
economy i think is fundamentally wrong
okay thank you very much